usually I do the introductions but I
this is you this is your guy this is my
guy I mean this is the original CJ - Kay
my man right here I didn't know what to
expect when I saw this guy in person as
a player like he was a rookie when he
was a rookie in that and in training
camp I was with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
so I that team is he'll tell you had a
bunch of Texas guys on the Tennessee
Titans team and they kept telling me man
this Chris Johnson there's a Balder man
we've never seen anybody so fast and I
was like yeah blahblahblah but then I
got there and yes one of the most
special talents I've ever been around
and then your memories of Chris Simmons
man he used to talk trash to me before
every game stop okay I think it was
probably like wheat or wheat like oh
come on I was I think I had and went 400
yards like rice like come on man on
telecine he's 1015 your your Iran's
break off some alone I picked that same
game
Linda broke for 80 and I came right back
and broke for like 70 City Kansas City
Kansas City Kansas City you like that's
when the smash and dash thing took off
right it did when those two big runs
yeah yeah and it was I think that's a
nickname that I feel like they try to
give to a lot of duo's now but you guys
were smashing yeah yeah we started that
they asked us like what was our name yes
England it was like we smashed in -
right he came over smash - then ever
since then they just started calling us
there every week smash and - okay we
have Mundel I'm in characters and
Lyndell especially a character I took a
whole time running back room oh yes and
and Lyndell we can put him on blast now
because his careers over he was late a
lot okay I mean late a lot right like
and always had a different excuse oh
right
how much weight goes is true like if we
had a 8:30 meeting Lyndell was and I
felt like never there at 8:30 never and
this is every day I mean at least once
or twice a week okay
and he'd always have some great excuse I
mean great what do you think his best
excuse was was one you remember you
remember
yeah we were he was late one time he
came in he was like man I had to pull
over to the gas station bathroom and my
stomach was hurt I had used just so he
his excuse was I took a crap and I had
thanked Griffin and then when he says
that the team explodes no actually
because it's a serious setting
I mean we're all shaking her head like
what a bunch of bullcrap that is but
there's nothing we could say cuz Jeff
Fischer is still the head coach and he's
down in front of the room and we're not
gonna buddy in that conversation so I
want to ask mr. four to four who's the
fastest guy in the NFL right now okay is
it unreal how fast he is he's fair I
mean like I'm not trying to disrespect
you or Joey Galloway or Deion Sanders
but he is the fastest guy I've ever seen
maybe he's a second of I want to say the
fast you invasive asses I know you're
gonna take yourself of course what what
was what was bigger the two thousand or
the four to four
mm hmm but the four to four we had never
seen before you got the watch made all
that yeah when you saw John Ross beat
the four to four i emoji that he sent
out soon as he ran the time remember
that official time men came in and he
tweeted I emoji was there out of you
that was like I hope that gets corrected
and it's actually a four to five
probably a part of my bass theater today
I don't believe he beat it you run it
for two to know when you look okay for
once when you look at the okay I poured
off on them at the end right that's fast
yeah number two is when have it ever
took that long for the first time you
take a long time you're right Wow that
it was rigged
they probably play with your shape Riley
got tired of tired of Joe never
highlight although yeah they probably
got tired of no one being there fair
like that the compound was getting
boring a conspiracy theory guy this is
one of the best ones I've ever heard I'm
telling
I don't believe it I have to imagine you
would go out and people would be like in
the club going I'll race you in the
parking lot yeah all the time all the
time that's just an area where
everywhere but dumbest crap ever yeah
yeah they don't know what they're
messing with since you are the master of
40 times we have some very famous
running clips from movies that we'd like
you to watch and tell us what you think
they're 40 times would be okay we're
gonna start off first
this is the scene from get out watch my
man run we all remember the scenes
here's the crap out of this guy running
straight Adam turns the last time that
form is phenomenal his elbows are
imperfect but that was for a while right
that was before when listen you're
running you're admitting that someone
may be faster than you yeah probably
Wow yeah all right next one is Mission
Impossible it is the crazy lunatic that
is Tom Cruise what do you think Tom
Cruise's for tea time was in Mission
Impossible yeah that's where you're
being generous
he's got the duck feet a little bit yes
right yeah I mean he's like for a dish
to mean no way he's beating me in a race
but he's going other stairs and
everything is slowing down
all right next one up much better movie
bad boys the king that is Will Smith run
it with a gun in hand and then he's got
to save Martin Lawrence what do you
think the top speed that will hit there
was he for a right there for a real
lower Will Smith now to a legendary
runner the Forrest Gump in the khakis
what do you think his top speed there
was he look forward to right there for
10 stops be right there right there
right and then the last one is Michael
Cera in Superbad as he's gonna run from
the cops here
out to the side crazy fascism I know how
definitely and thank you all right so
let's recap these you have get out as
your leader at for one coming in second
place Forrest Gump at four to third
place mission impossible Tom Cruise at
for three Will Smith shockingly gets
fourth place at a four eight and Michael
Cera appropriately five five do you
agree with his rankings I do I think I
thought maybe he was a hair nice to Tom
Cruise I agree
but other than that it's pretty good get
out beats Forrest Gump yeah are we going
into the sunken ways well good luck to
you my Frankie house a pleasure talking
to you thank you way to go